[Music]
hey it's time for our vegas drive series
this week we head over to the hoover dam
with the relaxing way to enjoy the
colorado river so grab your hat and
sunscreen as jillian takes us for a ride
you can experience the hoover dam like
never before through the lake mead
mojave adventures the day trip
experience begins at the lake mead rv
village where you are greeted by a tour
guide as you get ready for your journey
so to the left is lake mead lake mead is
the largest man-made reservoir in the
united states from interesting facts to
a level one security hidden path there
is a lot to experience just on the drive
to the raft so right now you are looking
at the mike o'callaghan and pat tillman
memorial bridge and from that bridge
down to the surface of the hoover dam is
almost a thousand feet and we're right
in the middle of it i am so excited
we're about to jump on a raft and go on
a hoover dam rafting adventure let's go
see what it's all about this is part of
the
black canyon national water trail so
this trip will start here at the base of
hoover dam and it will travel 11 miles
south to willow beach and we're going to
get a chance to see red tail hawks great
blue heron
bighorn sheep ospreys if we have a good
rain we have a lot of flowers floor and
fauna we'll see some splotches of yellow
out here which is called brittle bush
there's some still some historical sites
that we can you know get close to and
then point out
and as we were driving in here we're
trying to take pictures and video and i
feel like it doesn't do it of justice
you have to be in here to really see it
and take in the beauty what would you
say to people who maybe our locals don't
know this exists or how would you get
them to come out here well you have
these stunning views the general public
is not allowed where we're at so we have
access to this spectacular view of
hoover dam everybody else is looking up
on top trying to take a picture
and we have the ability to you're on a
raft kind of looking up from here you
see the dam and it's really in its glory
so what we started with about 30 almost
40 years ago is what we call a regular
run starts here at the base of hoover
dam travels 11 miles down to willow
beach it's a one-way smooth water
fully narrated motor-assisted raft trip
there are several different tours you
can embark on all showing you close-up
views of what the colorado river has to
offer and the guys that took
measurements did so manually up above
and a little bit to the right you can
see an old hand crank well i'm really
sad it's over but that's a wrap thank
you to kathleen for being the best tour
guide you guys have to check this out
it's the best day ever and i got a good
tan while i was out here see you guys
later
[Music]
too cute have you ever been over there